ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen mannschaft
fällt meine lieben freunde und wir
dürfen direkt zu beginn wieder gar nicht
lange zeit für den denn ich habe wieder
ultra fiel auf meiner to-do-liste hype
perfekt danke dir da komme ich packe ich
jetzt mal endlich in den dienstag 1
ich mag dich jetzt endlich in mit in
deine hunderte in der letzten folge
hatten sich darüber beschwert dass er im
regen draußen gestanden hatte obwohl er
ja hier die hundehütte ein paar blöcke
weiter hatte deswegen bleibt jetzt hier
sitzen gefällt es sehr gut wir müssen
direkt gar nicht mal hierhin gehen
sondern ich muss doch deinen kindern ich
muss meine neue spitzhacke machen weil
die erste aufgabe auf unserer riesigen
to do liste für die heutige folge ein
strip mining projekt sein wird wir
müssen nämlich wieder einmal nach unten
in unserer höhle gehen denn wir brauchen
extrem viele steine als boden für unsere
strandhaus villa
das habe ich in der letzten episode
bereits gesagt dass wir ich muss mich
auf jeden fall ein bisschen platz machen
für die ganzen spiele ich möchte den
kompletten boden meiner strandhaus will
ja voll mit grau gefärbten trocken beton
machen dazu wegen brauche ich dafür
allerdings eine menge steine die ich
darunter setzen weil trocken beton in
verbindung mit wasser ja getrocknet wird
das macht keinen sinn der sind vom
trocken beton ist ja das schon trocken
ist auf jeden fall brauche ich eine
menge steine die ich darunter packen
kann von daher würde ich sagen wir
bewegen uns das nahmen wir bewegen uns
rüber in unsere kleine mine hier vorne
die er in etwa auf der höhe der
diamanten ist die wir damals hier vorne
gefunden haben deswegen habe ich mich
dann auch in die wand gebohrt und ich
würde sagen wir fangen direkt an mit dem
schritt meinen
so meine lieben freunde ich habe mir
jetzt locker 76 bruchsteine geholt habe
auch eine menge kohle und eisen noch
gefunden würde jetzt sagen ich blende
euch jetzt nochmal ganz kleine time web
seien wieder nach oben laufen weil ich
echt eine menge durch gegraben mich
getan habe eigentlich sollte das
komplette projekte besser nicht sein
[Musik]
das schild steht du kriegst du kannst
mir meine fresse halten sehe ich auch so
genau
also ich gehe jetzt mal ganz kurz
schlafen und ich würde sagen dass leute
2 wächst hier hat sich nicht ausdenken
ist diese zombies auch nicht technik
ankommt hoch und läuft einfach in den
tod
so wie jetzt schlafen gehen und leute
treiben exil
[Musik]
leute 2 max hier denn es kann doch nicht
sein wo sind denn jetzt noch mehr
monster
ich habe tausende gräber getötet du bist
doch kein monster oder und leute 24
kannst du dich auch singen du kannst dir
das nicht ausdenken auf meiner insel
das ist doch keine normale mannschaft
insel mehr auf schwierigkeit normal hier
endlich kann schlafen meine lieben
freunde und ein neuer tag erwartet uns
auf unserer wunderschönen kleinen
mannschaft ich wäre jetzt einfach auf
das forderte fleisch wir scheißen okay
ich kann es eigentlich nicht kommen wir
haben wirklich ziele für heute von daher
laufen direkt darüber sollte zwei
macsteel und leute 2 max hier zwei jungs
wir laufen rüber zu unserer kleinen die
wird schon ziemlich riesig da vorne auf
jeden fall ist es unsere strandvilla und
ich freue mich so übertrieben wie geil
das hier schon aus sich mit diesen
quatsch blöcken einfach wir werden
nämlich als allererstes erstmal die
kreuzberg habe mich noch irgendwie genau
welche drin da kommt ein bisschen kohle
nachlegen und hier vorne haben wir auch
noch welche drin ich werde mir nämlich
jetzt erst mal einige glatze quartz
treppen machen davon brauche ich nämlich
insgesamt sieben stück und da fragt man
sich jetzt vielleicht luca wofür
brauchst du hier treppen sei das nicht
irgend ein bisschen doof aus
jetzt gerade sie aktuell wirklich
ziemlich doof aus ich glaube ich leider
den boden erst mit apples draußen der
kurzen tellabs so der komplette boden
bzw die ebene unter dem boden ist und
aus gekleistert mit cobblestone sieht
ziemlich cool aus hat ihnen die gerade
so ein schwimmbad vibes ich werde
dennoch jetzt mal dass hier noch aus
doch mal eben abbauen denn das braucht
mehr und das darf nicht nass werden und
danach erst noch diese blöcke hier
beziehungsweise kann ich ja auch
eigentlich schon stehen lassen denn wir
müssen das hier alles ja jetzt noch von
dem wasser befreien
mir wurde auch und in die kommentare
geschrieben luca wie geil wert wenn der
boden auf glas wäre dann könnte man halt
hier runter gucken und hätten hier so
die korallenriffe werde ich auch an 12
stellen machen allerdings erst im
nachhinein ich möchte erstmal die ganzen
bodenständig haben so wie ich sie mir
vorgestellt habe oder können im
nachhinein immer noch änderungen
anbringen allerdings würde ich sagen
jetzt mal ganz kurzer teilnimmt das
wasser entferne so ihr seht da hinten
die sonne schon untergehen das heißt ich
bewege mich mal wieder ganz schnell im
bettchen bevor ihr wieder 70.000 morgen
leute träumen existiert reaper über die
insel laufen
ich habe jetzt mehr oder weniger alles
fertig gekriegt da hinten muss nur noch
von partys blöcke abbauen und dann
können wir auch unseren trockenen grau
gefärbten
da hinlegen ich habe keine ahnung dass
genau welche abkürzungen warum schild er
denn da hinten wieder erster
bei der o das ging schnell das kann
nicht wahr sein man immer diese
komischen misst camping gabeln da und
nie lässt er alle davon fallen aber cool
wenn ich das ja auch fällt das ding
darunter na ja wir sind natürlich der
block wieder hin dass er mehr schön fein
säuberlich in der insel reparatur 2.0
jahres gemacht hat sich echt schön
entwickelt irgendwie unsere insel finde
ich na ja gut wir müssen darüber zu
unserer insel und wer denn jetzt endlich
mal den kompletten boden fertig kriegen
was auch noch mein plan für heute ist es
erstmal generell dass die folge mal
wieder ein bisschen kürzer wird die
letzte episode war ja fast eine halbe
stunde lang das war bisher die längste
folge die wir in den kompletten projekt
hatten aber auch so ein bisschen sonne
wiedergutmachungs folge von mir weil die
folge da vorher mit der face käme so ein
extremer von mir war also ich möchte
heute auf jeden fall keine riesige xxl
folge machen allerdings in der zeit in
der ich das sehr gerne aufnehmen
wirklich eine menge schaffen deswegen
freuen wir hier jetzt erstmal den kies
noch weg der jetzt von der text du ja
relativ ähnlich sehe ich gerade wieder
trocken beton will ich mir vorgestellt
habe
ich kann man gleich eine ecke rein kies
wollten einige kies klopp stehen lassen
dann könnte das miteinander vergleichen
der hellgraue wie heißt das hellgraue
trocken beton der sieht nämlich so aus
schon ein bisschen heller sie noch mal
ein bisschen cooler ausfindig also der
wird jetzt auf jeden fall überall hin
platziert von mir da hole ich mir die
restlichen blöcke noch mal eben von da
hinten aus der kiste
mir wurden die kommentare geschrieben
luca warum nimmst du nicht ein schwamm
ist doch deutlich einfacher ja ich weiß
dass es mit dem schwamm wahrscheinlich
deutlich einfacher ist den kann man dann
alle leute die nicht wissen was ein
schwamm in minecraft ist den kann sie
dann einfach hinsetzen
dann saugt er so ein bisschen das ganze
wasser auf die sache ist allerdings dass
ich nicht weiß wer sich ein schwarm
kräfte beziehungsweise nicht mehr weiß
ob man sich denn überhaupt kräften kann
oder immer nur finden kann
da ich auf jeden fall keinen schwamm
habe habe ich das jetzt einfach auf die
oldschool variante gemacht und einfach
die sachen hier abgebaut und
das wasser zu gebaut und das ganze dann
wieder abgebaut schlussendlich also dass
sie wird der boden auf jeden fall sein
erschreckt euch nicht gekommen natürlich
noch irgendwie teppiche drauf sowohl
teppiche die mir kräften wollte und an
einigen stellen werden wir auf jeden
fall auch noch den boden aus glas machen
zum beispiel im wohnzimmer bereich wenn
ich das ganz cool wenn wir dann so ein
sonderrat aquarium beziehungsweise wie
aus so alten james bond filmen wo man
dann auch so blättern in sachen rüber
gelaufen müssen danach unter dem die
piranhas her
die haben jetzt natürlich nicht in
minecraft aber wir stellen uns einfach
fordert die nemo fische dann piranhas
sind mir fällt auch gerade auf dass ich
definitiv zu wenig von dem trocken beton
habe ich weiß nicht ob ich da noch
irgendwas gelagert habe oder ob ich
falsch gerechnet habe aber eigentlich
brauchte ich 300 stück von entfernt habe
ich davon schon was braucht bin ich
mindestens noch 20 17 das sind 300 das
sind 340 ich idiot oder habe ich noch
welchem einem baumhaus ich schaue da
hinten auf jeden fall mal eben nach was
hier mit dem wasserfall passiert ist
weiß ich nicht so richtig ich glaube
hier ist ihm in der letzten oder
vorletzten folge in kryta explodiert
allerdings gegen die folge hat zwei
stunden und ich wusste ja dann nicht
mehr genau was mit der festkelter teil
war deswegen hat mich dass da versucht
zu reparieren aber nicht hingekriegt
hier vorne drin nämlich hier haben wir
auch keinen trocken getan habe ich dem
nicht irgendwo doch hier achten 50
trocken beton ich nehme jetzt auch noch
mal ein bisschen sand mit erde auch an
den das ist grobe er die können wir
nicht gebrauchen
allerdings habe nicht noch irgendwo kies
oder so dass wir auch noch ein balsam
für meine seele dann könnten wir damit
auch noch mal so ein bisschen was machen
allerdings nicht am start von daher
würde ich sagen muss man mit dem
arbeiten was wir haben
ich hoffe mal dass diese 60 trocken
beton noch ausreichen sollten balu wie
geht's dir
perfekt ich weiß nicht was herr einfach
aber ich kräfte balu jetzt einfach mal
einen kesseln einmal wasser habe ich
schon mit dabei oder werde ich ihn
zumindest mal so ein bisschen was zu
trinken platzieren beziehungsweise wenn
ich gerade schon hier bin kann ich auch
kurz auch mir eben das verrottete
fleisch mitnehmen dann kriegt dann aber
wie ein bisschen was neues zu essen tür
zu und den kessel platziere ich jetzt
aber mal so ein bisschen
[Musik]
also ich mag dich ihren kessel im boden
mit wasser rein jetzt ein bisschen
fleisch wird kassiert
wohin willst du noch wasser ich nehme
jetzt allerdings mal die 58 trocken wir
kommen die wir uns vor hinten aus dem
baum haus geholt haben und versucht das
hier mit so ein bisschen zu machen das
geht aber auch auf gar keinen fall
reichen also ich weiß nicht wo ich mich
da so krass verrechnet habe dass ich das
wieder nicht hinkriege hier mit den
materialien die ich habe aber wir können
ja einfach mal gucken ob man sich nicht
doch noch ein wunder entwickelt macht so
viel fehlt mir das sind 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
mal 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 also sechs mal acht
sind 34 brauchen wir auf jeden fall noch
von daher würde ich sagen lasse ich mir
auf jeden fall noch ein bisschen was
machen mussten sind nur fische die haben
auf jeden fall noch grauen farbe haben
wir auch nicht mehr wie so doof ich bin
mir jetzt sagt da hinten rüber und mir
sand und macht mir trocken beton so 64
hellgrauen trocken beton damit sollte es
auf jeden fall möglich sein dass hier
vorne zu füllen also hier alles zu bei
uns exakt zack zack zack zack zack zack
zack zack und hier noch die letzten drei
reihen erste reihe ist voll
zweite reihe ist voll und dritte reihe
ist auch voll dass sie ist der boden auf
jeden fall von unserem haus hier kommen
auf jeden fall noch gleich ich nehme
jetzt im bett hier mit der über 80 schon
schön ja alles nach vorne doch nicht
strandvilla fertig ist der ganze bahnhof
jemals ausgeleuchtet ist hinten dann die
tiere lasst mich einfach in ruhe wir
gehen jetzt auf jeden fall noch mal ganz
kurz hier vorne rein und schauen uns den
ganzen apparat erstmal bei tageslicht
anders sieht ja schon ziemlich cool aus
man kann sich herum dann wahrscheinlich
noch immer nicht so viel vorstellen
allerdings werde ich euch jetzt erst mal
zeigen wie ich mir das mit den treppen
hier vorne vorgestellt habe die ich mir
vorhin gemacht habe dafür benötige ich
diese treppen und gras blöcke
beziehungsweise werde ich denke ich erst
mal das ganz kurz mit dem gras machen
und mit dem kloster nun mit den eisen
falltüren die ich mir bereits in der
letzten oder vorletzten folge gemacht
habe denn hier kommt ganz clean graz hin
hier natürlich braucht kein gras blog
das will ich jetzt aber auch direkt zu
haben damit es schön aussieht und die
beiden ersetze ich auch mal ganz kurze
müsste uns gleich auf jeden fall noch
ein paar mehr graz geholt damit cool
aussieht allerdings kommt er hier oben
auf die höhe erstmal unser dach oder
[Musik]
hier oben kommt auf jeden fall das dach
so rüber das deutlich jetzt erstmal nur
hier mit so ein bisschen an damit ich da
auf jeden fall in den nächsten folgen
bescheid weiß und jetzt zeige ich euch
ganz gut was ich mir für die
außenfassade vorgestellt habe dann hier
wollte ich eins zwei drei vier fünf
blöcke freilassen und dann hier oben
zwei glos ton hin hier oben auch zwei
glos zorn hin und hier oben auch zwei
große bonn hin
darunter kommen eisen falltüren das
sieht natürlich nach nochmal deutlich
besser aus aber da kommt das licht dann
durch den klostersee die nachher nicht
dass sie dann auf jeden fall bedeutet
nicht besser aus allerdings wenn man
dann quasi hier ankommt dann geht das
dach quasi hier über das ganze stockwerk
und das ist dann auf der höhe also und
jetzt gerade wirklich wie gesagt don't
judge me a judge me later
englisch mit luca vorne bauen wir jetzt
allerdings direkt mal den trocken beton
ab und zwar sieben blöcke in jede
richtung zack zack und zakir fordern
darf ich das jetzt noch nicht abbauen
schlampig weil dahinter wasser kommen
soll
deswegen werde ich mir das mal ganz von
anderer seite erst mal kurz anschauen
das müssten wenn ich mich jetzt nicht
komplett irre die blöcke hier hinter dem
gras sein oder ich habe das mal ganz
kurz an 123 blogger auf jeden fall rind
23 genau da muss ich hier auf jeden fall
so eine zweite linie nochmal hinter
bauen dass wenn ich die blöcke abbauen
das dann schlussendlich nicht der beton
das wird weil dann verändert sich der
beton halt direkt in den anderen farbton
und das will ich nicht deswegen wenn ich
das jetzt ab jetzt können wir den
apparat ja auf jeden fall wieder abbauen
und ihr seht jetzt relativ fix was ich
meine denn wenn das nur einmal mit
wasser in berührung kommen haben wir
hellgrauen beton und nicht mehr den
hellgrauen trockenen beton
was wir allerdings benötigen und jetzt
sollte es glaube ich klappen genau jetzt
ist hinter die erde perfekt ist dass ich
wollte diese glückliche abbauen und
treppen hinsetzen das macht jetzt
vielleicht keinen großen unterschied von
außen nachher schon 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 und
dann kommt hier noch mal da können wir
jetzt einfach mal wieder bruchstein hin
packen und hier vorne wollte ich dann
graf hinsetzen davon habe ich allerdings
bei o2 mit 1 ich brauche mir gras und
baue ich so nicht reparieren auch mal
eben ganz kurz meine gold spitzhacke
hier die geht ja immer extrem schnell
habe ich es ist halt das einzige
behutsamkeit seiten was ich gerade habe
deswegen muss ich darauf auf jeden fall
acht geben so jetzt zeigen euch mal ganz
kurz was ich mir gedacht habe und zwar
nehme ich mir dafür erst mal die
grasberger die ich vorhin abgebaut habe
die kombination die mich hier schon mal
rum
umsetzen so ein bisschen als stopper
dafür dass das wasser nicht mit dem
hellgrauen trocken beton in berührung
kommt er nämlich jeder an stattfindet
ich nehme einen wassereimer und
platziere jetzt hier unter die stufen so
ein bisschen wasser davon ist jetzt
wasser drin und jetzt laufen wieder
rüber produzieren wir 2010 packen das
dann hier vorne rein gehen mal wieder
hierhin nehmen uns was raus packten das
dann hier vorne unter die stufe und das
machen wir aus dem grund weil man dann
hier vorne das wasser nicht sieht
beziehungsweise von der anderen seite
wenn er dann der rasen gemacht wird und
so die das alles ein bisschen besser aus
dort ist nicht so einfach ist es weg und
von hier vorne sieht also auch ein
bisschen china aus denn ich werde dass
ich jetzt wieder zu bauen mit dem gras
blöcken und jetzt da da da da da da habe
ich nicht dabei jetzt können wir jetzt
so ein bus drauf pflanzen
das sieht dann glaube ich ganz cool aus
ein bisschen muss in der bude was ihr
vorne noch erstmal hinkommt ist ich weiß
nicht ob ich das hier schon mit dabei
habe habe ich natürlich auch nicht mit
dabei wenn ich euch an anders sagen wir
vorne kommt die kleine pflanze noch rein
hier hinten kommt dann die küche hin
allerdings benötigen wir zuerst er noch
einmal einige gefärbte glasscheiben
dafür wandel nicht dass ihr allerdings
benötigen wir erstmal noch einige
gefärbte glasscheiben ich weiß nicht ob
so ging genau 8 und wir brauchen auch
noch mal acht stück denn insgesamt 16
müssen am start sein die wir noch für
hier vorne brauchen denn das hier wird
natürlich selbst wahrscheinlich noch
rübergezogen zack zack zack und da oben
kann ich auch generell noch mal eben
schnell mit dem glatten quad so ein
bisschen her gehen und das mit der
anderen seite hier vorne nun endlich
verbinden können nämlich ein bisschen
entspannter die schwarzen glasscheiben
hinsetzen die hier vorne lang laufen
soll und hier oben dann zu
dann sieht das nämlich so aus wie eine
große wand die komplett aber so ein
bisschen abgedunkelt ist seht ihr links
mit dem vergleich das wenn ich ein
bisschen zu hält und hier dass die
person american muscle beach miami aus
bist du da sind ja auch alle fenster so
getönt und hier vorne sich das
allerdings auch ganz geil ausfindig wenn
man dann so ein bisschen über den ozean
guckt wer halt geil wenn man dass da
hinten noch sehen könnte ich könnte
eventuell mal die ränder distance ein
bisschen hoch
schon geil oder sie herauskommen dass
sie wieder hinten sogar die berge das
festland und dann zu anderen seite wenn
man da hingucken denen er komplett quasi
unsere insel
wenn sie jetzt ist nach ganz hinten
gucken habe ich jetzt die sichtweise
auch auf eine ahnung wie weit gestellt
also wir können auch da hinten komplett
hingucken ich glaube ich stell dich doch
mal ein bisschen weiter runter die sonst
immer so auf 18 chance weil ich es doch
besser finde wenn man dass da hinten nur
so leicht erahnen kann
wir sehen da hinten die insel aber das
hier hinten das fest noch nicht so
richtig aber gut das soll auf jeden fall
so bleiben hier vorne kommt die küche
hin dass schaffen in der heutigen
episode leider nicht mehr ich möchte
eigentlich am liebsten heute auch noch
in den neckar gehen weil wir noch eine
menge quatsch brauchen ich habe wirklich
absolut gar nichts mehr was wir noch
machen könnten wäre allerdings das was
ich vorhin bereits für die ecke
angekündigt habe und zwar brauchen wir
dafür ein fass und zweimal eichenlaub
eichenlaub habe ich hier freunde nicht
drin wo habe ich nämlich ob und genau
hier davon nämlich mit zwei mit und ich
weiß nicht ob ich hier noch ein fast
drin habe habe ich allerdings leider
nicht dann nehme ich mir einfach dass
hiermit und die sechs da kann ich das
nämlich einfach so hierhin packen und so
und zack zack dann habe ich ja ein fass
und die beiden reichen laub teile
damit möchte ich nämlich so eine art ex
lanze darstellen
ich wollte heute eigentlich noch die
küche schaffen habe ja bereits gesagt
ich habe es allerdings nicht ich weiß es
tut mir leid freunde diese ganzen bau
folgen ich weiß es die ein bisschen
langweilig sind so es geht nichts große
ab und so weiter und so fort aber ich
möchte halt dieser strand fehler
wirklich fertig bauen das ist ist er das
größte projekt in diesem projekt
minecraft mit luca hier vorne soll er
die wasser vor der insel hin ich habe
mir auch überlegt eine blumeninsel zu
machen mit den ganzen blumen die ich
letztens abgebaut habe und dort dann
auch die hühnchen hin packen zu lassen
damit wir quasi sonne blumeninsel haben
oder die ganzen chicken nuggets darauf
rum laufen hier vorne allerdings ob ich
mir das so vorgestellt ein fass und die
beiden darauf damit seine kleine ex
lanze und wenn man so guckt könnte das
schon fertig sein und dann dreht man
sich um und dann sieht es noch so aus
aber das wird schon meine lieben freunde
ich würde an der stelle allerdings die
heutige episode minecraft mit luca jetzt
erst mal beenden
es tut mir leid das ist heute ein
bisschen kürzer registriert wurde die
gestern war aber auch gefühlt so ein
halber kurzfilm deswegen wenn es euch
gefallen hat das gar einen daumen hoch
und ein video hier da abonniert main
kanal
falls doch keine luxus und wenn er schon
älter dann klicken auf die glocke dann
verpasst neue videos von mir nicht mehr
bekommt eine benachrichtigung per handy
sobald ich was neues opladen und lasst
mich morgen abend wieder der fall sein
morgen um 20 uhr kommt die neue episode
minecraft mit lukas schreibt mir jetzt
gerne in die kommentare was ich da
machen soll würde ich weiter an der
strandvilla baut also dementsprechend
die hölle gehen ein bisschen farmen hier
so ein bisschen bauen die küche das
wohnzimmer den ganzen bereich oder soll
ein bisschen was entdecken sondern
wiederum verbot spend es uns in die
kommentare hier dürft entscheiden bis
morgen
[Musik]